listen man you know I'm such a fan of
your work but I have to say that you are
exceptional in this movie thank you
you're so good I have to know you've
read so many scripts um what was it
actually like reading this one because
it's so unique and different and very
hard to quantify yeah and that really
spoke to me Steve
because I like movies that are original
that have that feeling of brand newness
to them um I like movies that aren't
afraid to tell a different kind of
story
uh you know I said there are only five
scripts where I in 45 years of doing
this where I feel I have to have to have
to make that movie and those scripts are
leaving Las Vegas vampires kiss
adaptation bringing out the dead and
dream scenario I didn't want to change a
word now other scripts I've made have
been great but they but most like like
while hard it evolved you know it wasn't
necessarily on the page or other movies
I made but what also was at work here
for me was that I could put some of my
life experience in terms of my emotions
into Paul Matthews he doesn't a lot of
thought went into designing his look
even changing my voice the way I dress
the way I walk to be as far away from
so-called me as as we might think so
that you could lose yourself in the
character of Paul Matthews but
emotionally I
remember
feeling no sense of control over what
was happening to me on the internet the
Nicholas Cage loses his you know
all that stuff turning into a memic
cherry-picking freakout scenes meltdowns
without any sense of act one or to or
how the character got to that crisis and
going I can't I can't stop this this
isn't why I became an actor it's not why
I made the movie this is something new
and it wasn't until I read dream
scenario that I said to myself now I can
take those feelings and I can apply them
to something constructive I would not
have been able to play Paul Matthews and
connect with you if I had not gone
through that experience that whole
apology video I meant it man that that
was that was me reacting to what was
happening to my body of work through
these mashups I'm very curious you when
you're making something you really don't
know how it's going to turn out and when
did you realize oh wait this is
something special and people are really
responding to it well I knew right away
this this one I knew right away uh I sat
down with Christopher we had coffee
together before a year before we even
started working together and I knew
because of the way
he presented himself his thoughts his
the level of intelligence the fact that
that he wrote this script which again is
so original I knew that whatever we did
that something
special would would would emerge what
the level of that specialness was who
can really say but but I knew that it
would be a worthwhile effort I was in
the world premiere at the Toronto Film
Festival and I uh felt the audience I
mean I reacted very strongly but I felt
that audience what was it like for you
actually at that world premiere and and
having all those people you know what I
mean respond to your work oh it's great
I mean you know you know me I've been on
the receiving end of tomatoes and like
Gary Ol Man said Applause is never to be
taken lightly I was thankful I really
appreciate it I I was touched and I
loved it you know and I'm glad you were
there at that screening because that was
a fun one I also found fun is that you
wear a um the Talking Heads suit and and
they had a film at the Toronto Film
Festival you know the it was just one of
those full circles I'm like get the F
out of here fantastic coincidence but I
mean you know me Steve you and I have
spoken a million times and you know
we've talked about how I approach movies
and what's important to me so you know
why this movie is so meaningful to me
because I feel like it's it's a it's a
perfect summation of everything I want
to be doing right now you the other
thing about this film which I really
really dig is that I did not I was not
able to guess what was going to be the
next scene and that's beautiful yeah
exactly you know well that's the thing
like I me both you and I see a lot of
movies you probably more than even me um
but one of the things is that like you
sometimes you just can guess everything
and this you know there there's no guess
you're not GNA know where go and see and
I think you and I have a similar taste
in that regard I want to be surprised
it's like I if I go have dinner
somewhere I want the chef to let me know
what what do you think is great just
surprise me I want to get knocked out by
something I'm not expecting I want a new
taste I don't want that same thing over
and over again you know now look it the
comic book movie I will say one thing
about it all right to be
fair comic books by Nature are episodic
as a child reading it I want to get to
the next issue so what they're doing is
just having the comic book experience
applied to to the movie goinging
experience okay I can't wait for the
this one or that I want to see the new
issue instead of reading I want look at
it so that they're that's truthful to
the comic book experience but that's not
where I'm at what I want to do is I want
to find I want to keep doing the
independently spirited dramas I want to
keep making movies that I as a student
I'm not a master I'm a student will
learn something from which explains my
whole filmography which is why I did the
adventure films because I wanted to do
something new and see if I could make it
work um I don't want to play it safe but
the independent drama has always been
where one can really take the chances
and find something original and try
something which may or may not work but
at least you're you're trying to hit
that Mark and I'm happy to say that in
my view dream scenario is a masterpiece
and I don't what do I mean by
Masterpiece something which is is the
work of a Craftsman that is so fine that
nothing needs to be added taken awar
alter and I think that Christopher did
something for his sophomore effort that
is that you know and that's why I'm I'm
happy that yeah it came together the way
it did people ask this question all the
time but I'm being very sincere when I
ask this of you you get offered I'm sure
a lot of different scripts is there
something because you've done so much in
your amazing career that you are still
anxious to do in terms of a genre or you
know a type of character that you have
not played I mean the only genre that I
don't think I've really done is the
musical but and I don't think I'm
necessarily the greatest choice for a
musical but it would be a challenge and
it would be something that I might learn
from um but right now you know I'm
approaching 60 so my thinking is like
okay what's the best usage of my time
you start thinking about things like
time when you hit 60 uh you know my dad
left when he was 75 so I'm like okay
what's the priority well my daughter is
the priority my my you know my kids and
I got to start thinking about what can I
do to keep the Mind fur I got to read
more books
um and then you know if there's
something that comes along let's say you
know I get a call from a director maybe
it's going to be his last movie you know
maybe that's interesting maybe I should
do that with that person who knows or
she her it's going to be her last m
whatever it is you know there are
different criteria that go in but the
main thing for me really is to is to
keep it as personal as I can so I still
have these conversations with you and
you're still relating to or connecting
with it in some way where it doesn't
feel fake you know I yeah design of the
look of the character the movement the
voice that's that's all craft but the
the inherent emotion I have to back it
up with genuine life experience and
whatever feelings I can apply to it so
you don't you don't feel like I'm
acting I I know exactly what you mean
and sir I'm out of time I'm just going
to say it's always a pleasure to talk
with you and you really are exceptional
in this movie thank you so much have a
great day I'll I'll speak to you again
soon I'm
sure